are going to start with style today ross
because the guardian is reporting
that the fashion world is expecting a
huge
boom they've already seen an uptick in
clothing and jewelry sales and they're
comparing it to
the roaring 20s fashion after the 1918
flu in world war one the fashion world
exploded
men switched from suits to sports coats
and women got bobs and put on beaded
dresses
and fashion experts expect to see the
same joy and freedom
expressed in upcoming trends what do you
think well i think people are
a couple things one i would love to have
somewhere to go where i had to dress up
it's been a minute right it'd be nice to
feel good get all pretty and go
the other thing though is i've gotten
sort of used to wearing elastic head to
toe
24 7 right yeah and so i think that
whatever happens in the fashion world
that athleisure-ness
which is that like casual athlete when
you wear stretchy clothes but you're not
going to the gym that's called
athleisure
yeah i think it's all going to be
infused with that like i just got these
jeans and they're so
stretchy i feel like i could put on 20
pounds and still fit in them and i have
all these
these pants that are like draw steering
and elastic i feel like everything's
just leaning that way and i'm fine with
it
yeah well i want people to be on you
know
some form of making their clothes and
their lives a personal billboard
because like nature it goes you know
underground and then you have this
incredible rebirth and
burst of color and awe and i think that
we as humans should embrace and follow
in nature's footsteps
so there is someone out there in the
world who i have been
a huge fan of and following very closely
on social media
he's a young ceo from the uk who founded
the very disruptive
global marketing agency called the
social change
and he dropped out of college and became
an entrepreneur and since then he's done
it all against the grain
and i can't get enough of his insights
on twitter
please welcome to the show steven
bartlett
hi stephen
[Applause]
it's it's a pleasure to be i mean that
was an amazing set of compliments i i've
been blushing and laughing at the same
time thank you so much
well it's true i really feel like when i
read
your posts um i raise an eyebrow
and i'm like yeah yeah that is powerful
that is
some important wise advice on our
behaviors
and we are accountable for our behaviors
and i really get that from you
is that you know why do you think that
it's important to put out these messages
that you do to people
do you know what the the the slightly
paradoxical thing is
i'm putting out all of this stuff for
myself i'm trying to understand myself
that the flaws i have
the toxic traits that i have and i'm
trying to become more self-aware
and the best way to learn often is to
write and so i write these things for
myself in my diary
and once in a while if i can condense it
into something that i think people will
understand and resonate with
i'll share it with the world and the
feedback as well helps me build on the
thoughts so
it's an incredibly selfish pursuit but
um i'm so glad to hear that it's uh that
it's had some value for you
everything you just said i'm like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um your new book happy sexy millionaire
is all about your unique path to success
and it's about to come out and we're so
excited for it
do you have something that you want a
piece of advice
even one piece of advice that you might
want people to take away from your
business journey in this book
yeah so the title right happy sexy
millionaire the reason that the book's
called that is at 18 years old
as a very insecure black broke
university dropout
i wrote in my diary that i wanted to be
a happy sexy millionaire because
well i thought being a sexy millionaire
would make me happy and so
over the next five years that's what i
strive to become
right i built a 200 million business
global business i
bought that car that i wrote about my
diary i got the girlfriend
um because the things that had
invalidated me when i was younger were
the things that i inevitably sought
validation from
as an adult as we all do and it was in
realizing that it was my insecurities
that were driving me not my intrinsic
internal desires not the things that i
really loved
that was the moment when i when i was
able to turn my life and really go after
happiness and
the conclusive point in the book is that
in order to
to strive for the right things for the
right reasons you first have to know
that you are
enough or you'll make the mistake i did
and you'll you'll you'll run after the
wrong things for the wrong reason fix
thinking that pleasure and
external validation equals happiness so
really the book is about giving you that
foundation that you are already enough
and that's the foundation that'll let
you chase uh your your best
your best life i love that 18 years old
you're writing happy sexy
millionaire in your diary at 18 i wrote
i want to meet ginger spice
in my diary did you ever meet me i did
actually i did so you know what we're
sort of the same person you know in many
ways
stephen would you care to join us in a
headline
i'd love to we'd be honored ross take it
away all right stephen we're starting
with a breath of fresh air
and this one comes from automaker giant
gm
that's a big car manufacturer well
reuters reports the gm
is going to go all electric by 2035
that's a game changer it means they'll
be phasing out all new gas
and diesel cars and trucks and this push
to fully eliminate tail pipe emissions
came from gm ceo
mary barra who's you know the top of the
top and other companies are expected to
follow
and it's all about the environment but
it's also about the bottom line it's
about business because california
announced the sale of new gas powered
vehicles would be illegal starting in
2035
other states are expected to join them
so if these manufacturers want to make
money they have to follow
these new guidelines and switch to um
electric cars now i have had electric
car for a while and i know
and i was so intimidated to do it you
know i wanted to to do it for my
footprint
and it quickly became the new normal you
know it was confusing at first but
then i had a friend come over and say oh
i need to get gas where's the gas
station near your house and i was like
oh i i have no idea and i think that
that's kind of the shift a lot of us are
going to have to do
if we want to save this earth it's just
got to become the new normal but
how does it affect the business industry
you think stephen
you've hit the nail on the head in a
number of ways there i too
used to have this big range over sport
that's the car that i wrote about in my
diary when i was 18.
i got it at 24. i sold it at 26 and
bought an electric bike
instead so i now just have an electric
bicycle no other vehicle right
i want to say thank you to general
motors for recognizing the existential
threat
that is climate change i want to say
thank you to the legislators as you've
highlighted
california for leading the way and
giving them no choice and
i feel like we should thank tesla and
elon because
that the singular sort of company vision
they have was to accelerate
the advent of electric vehicles not to
win to make others
catch up with what is inevitably the
future and to eliminate this existential
threat which is climate change
and stephen i will add to this um
tesla made it sexy and you know what
amen that works and that's why you know
um your book has that word in it as well
sexy sells and it's good and there's
nothing wrong with that
amen well i completely agree
i cannot thank you enough uh stephen
bartlett for coming here today i am so
grateful um
and um and your new book happy sexy
millionaire will be out everywhere
tomorrow hi congratulations
thank you so much thank you steven
[Music]
you